hey everybody uh in black widow i play  red guardian  a superhero spy but he's also a dad  so are you ready for some zingers if we  must  hey hey guys why did the black widow  wear a disguise because she was a spider  oh my god i don't even have to read them  from the book  i know them what are a spy's favorite  type of shoes  sneakers  hey guys you like that one guys what do  you call a canadian spy  a double agent  i myself don't even like that one uh  last week i discovered  an australian gorilla uh spying on me  and you know what i told him you know  what i said i said hey  don't pry mate  don't mate but it's also  like the word primate hey  uh guys clint barton's brother has a  super  smelling ability they call him  hawk nose good this real name is oh [ __ ]  i just admit it you love my dreams i  actually liked a few